Tony starting off this hour in taxes hi
Tony how are you hello how you doing
better than I deserve
man thank you what's up hey there you go
I have a few questions man um you know
I've been struggling with this the last
couple of years I owe everything I have
I'm about $150,000 in debt
I have trouble suspending a job man what
do i do I do
I'll side by side a mobile home about
40,000 for the mobile home park percent
interest on back on my side by side I
own seven percent Interest about
eighteen thousand for that on my two
pieces alone the one with my mobile home
on the one I live on and I owe about
40,000 with that and it has 12 percent
interest on that and another piece of
land that I owe about twenty thousand on
and I don't own no interest on that
don't know really what to do at this
point are you working now
no I start my new job on the 25th of
this month you said you've had a hard
time keeping a job why don't know I just
not not because I get fired or anything
like that but just just can't you know
don't go to work don't know what the
problem is I mean I'm sorry you can't go
to work what do you mean yeah I did I
just have to leave the job I mean you
leave the job why would you walk home
I'm a job I don't know yeah you do
so I mean that's random you know yeah so
here's the thing here's the thing dude
there's two sides to the equation yeah
the income side and the outgo side and
you know creating when you can go create
an income with this thing called work
you are your most powerful wealth
building tool how old are you okay all
right you graduate from high school yes
Gidi okay and what kind of jobs have you
walked away from on top in two thousand
dollars a week jobs anywhere from 1,500
to 2,000 dollars doing what you don't
want
I do I build foundations for like
transmission lines and substations and
this last job I was on we built a fish
hatchery okay so you've been doing
construction work and you've been making
thousand two thousand dollars you're
making fifty to 100 grand a year depend
on how much you work yeah okay was your
dad a hard worker yeah okay
I'm curious why that didn't rub off yeah
Tony here's new here's the thing man I
must say this the common denominator is
you you know it bothers me at 35 years
old
you're my age that you don't know why
you're you're you don't have a job so
before we can address the income part
you you got to get a job and keep a job
I mean at the end of the day you know
because you can't get an income if you
won't if you won't stay on the job yeah
let me here's the thing you become who
you hang around with and so my guess is
is that maybe you've been hanging around
with people that are acting the same
why and so you may need to choose more
carefully who it is you spend time with
you speak like the people you hang
around with you work like the people you
hang around with you read the same books
watch the same TV shows that people you
hang around we all do we know this about
little kids that's why we don't let our
little kids run around the juvenile
delinquents you know your kids gonna be
a juvenile delinquent you run around
with you know who you run around with
who and my guess is is that you've kind
of gotten caught in this thank God it's
Friday oh god it's Monday culture yeah a
group of friends that think that way
they live for the weekend and you know
party up all their money on the weekend
and make absolutely no progress and and
so it's up to you you can do what you
want to do but you called Nast so when
you want you ask I'm obligated to tell
you so I think you've got you know if
I'm you if I were your older brother I
put my arm around your shoulder and kick
your butt absolutely and cause you say
hey man you're gonna have to discipline
up here you're going to have some self
discipline and stick with some of these
good jobs and then once you've got that
steady income because you stay on the
job
you don't just wander off which is so
random man you don't just wander off
then you know you can say okay which
piece of land do I want to keep which
one do I want to sell and then let's pay
off than what I'm going to keep sell the
other one if we're gonna live in this
mobile home let's get paid off and
that's a first step that maybe we build
a house on that property someday because
the mobile homes not a good long-term
investment and either the side by side
for that matter and so you know you get
this stuff paid off and if you're gonna
have toys and stuff like that you got to
have them paid off and that means
working and you work like a crazy man to
hit those goals and and you know what if
you had zero debt how would that feel
that feel great but that's gonna require
a lot of steady consistent work and so
you know you might want to look around
go hey who in my life what supervisor
have I had that had his crap together or
what friend of I had this seem to have
his act together and then sit down with
them and
hey man would you walk with me and help
me get dialed in on this because I'm
struggling with this
sometimes you need a good good man in
your corner to to push you along but you
know until you get that diligence thing
up you're gonna struggle struggle a lot
too I mean here's the thing Dave he was
making $2,000 a week that's $6,000 a
month living in Texas that's good money
yeah good money I mean so it's the
mental to me but you and I have both
known people like that one were growing
up absolutely I still know people think
that me too me too
but they're not my close friends yeah
they're not at all because I because
I've become who I hang around with yes
so they do check out a good church in
your area you may find some guys there
that walk with you too and that might be
good for your heart